yeah right but
i say that because you and i have heard
i'm sure everyone's heard it's been 400
years
of trying to get changed yeah now that
you guys are doing this how do you
reconcile trying to tell your players
your team other players the public that
just because it hasn't been enough
change
that you still can't stop you still have
to keep fighting how do you deal with
that
knowing that we're still dealing with
these situations
well you know change didn't happen a lot
of times quickly either
um and and i think uh our players
actually kind of learned that over the
last couple days that
um you know the one i'm going to start
with this that the players were
phenomenal
um i was fortunate enough they invited
me to sit in on the meetings
and you know all of them um there's been
so many
different reports but just from a
fly on the wall um i was just so
impressed with them
the meeting last night i thought i was
really impressed because
you know you learn a lot of things um
you know number one that um
you know the players and the owners are
partners
and um it didn't have to be a
contentious meeting and it wasn't
uh it was a discussion about what they
needed what they wanted
and you know adam and the owners were on
board
with what's most of it or all of it and
even the things that they didn't
come to an agreement on they discussed
so just to start
there is great uh but you're right you
know just because something
hasn't happened doesn't mean it can't
happen
and uh like i've always don't give in to
something that hasn't happened
uh keep pushing keep working um
the key to this thing is that um i think
that
we all needed to take a breath you know
we needed a
moment to breathe um
it's not lost on me that that george
floyd didn't get that moment
you know but we did
and we took it um and the players took
it
and they they got to refocus on on the
things that
they wanted to focus on outside of their
jobs
and then they voiced it they organized
it
they got it together they understood
they can't do everything
on their own uh that we all need help to
get things done
um and they then they went out and they
got that help as well
so again just the pride to be in the nba
um it was was very high for me i i slept
very well last night
um thinking that uh our young people
spoke and and that was fantastic
thank you thanks bt uh
next up we have uh um go ahead home
hey doc um yesterday you spoke about how
emotional it was for your team like
wednesday night they went from thinking
that it was over to
thursday we're playing again and playing
for championship i mean it sounds like
the world has really kind of changed
inside the bubble in the last 48 hours
for you guys
what's the challenge of getting back on
the court mentally and
just refocusing on playing basketball
again won't it feel different playing
on sunday as opposed to saying what you
guys played the last time you were on
the court
i don't know if they'll feel different
or not what's never lost to me is my job
you know at the end of the day um it's
not the nba's job to solve the world
it's the nba's job to be part of the
world
um and and so uh i think we've
accomplished that part
uh but you still have to do your jobs uh
you know i think that today may be a
tough day and even you know whenever we
play tomorrow but
uh will be a tough day practice wise
just to get refocused
uh but i do think that the couple days
off will help in that fact as well
thanks
doc uh next question is going to come
from cassidy down in orlando
um this poem today said being in that
room specifically on wednesday night was
unlike anything we had
ever seen in this 15 years
how would you describe what that feeling
was to have all those players and
coaches
in that room what what what was that
feeling like it was awesome
cassidy again and i don't even know that
meeting went well
you know that meeting had a lot of uh
anger a lot of voices a lot of emotion
uh
i think i've learned long ago you know
emotion is great you know
being emotional sometimes it's not you
know what i mean
uh and but it was out there
we got to hear what people felt and
thought
um so to me that was very powerful you
know that's what i told our guys
the players that this is a powerful
moment uh you guys are learning how
powerful you can be
and then i was proud of them um but then
to come back that next morning
and it was amazing the difference they
got it out then they could talk and then
the third meeting
now we could work i just thought the
progression of that was
was absolutely perfect
thanks cassidy doc next question is from
dan wilkie
um kind of a couple ones that are all
sort of related um
you know the you said progress is slow
in this stuff
but one of the things players were able
to accomplish was a commitment
on nba arenas to be used as polling
places yeah
that's already been moving in a little
bit in that direction but to get
you know houston yesterday utah today i
assume more will come
after that how important was it to see
something tangible
and then i think secondly um you know
you mentioned being a part of the world
players are on cnn people are talking
now
but in a week or two weeks it's going to
be the conference finals and the stakes
on the court are going to be higher and
then it'll be the nba finals and the
stakes will be higher still
how can how can that not overshadow
the real work and is that going to be is
that even possible
i don't know if it's possible or not i
think that's up to the players and it's
up to
you guys you know to keep the talk going
listen the stakes are high now
you know uh for players and coaches
you know we've had a couple coaches fire
uh
you know after they lost so i don't
think anybody that plays a game thinks
the stakes aren't high now
um but after the game um or whenever you
feel like it
uh you can still speak out and you don't
have to speak out
it's not your job some guys choose to
i've always choose to do it
um but there's no
demand like that you have to uh i think
everybody
should do whatever is comfortable in
their space and we can keep doing it i
just think there's so many guys that
will
that there's no way that their voice
will be drowned out um
during the finals or the conference
finals um
because when you think about it we have
even more media uh
that is there to get our voice out so um
i think that'll be good
and doctor what the the polling places
it's awesome you know i was already i'm
already on the board
um you know for the election super
centers
uh project and that's what we're doing
uh lebron has his group
uh that was the other thing by the way
it was really cool that people
understood you can all have your
different groups
but you still do it together uh and
and you know that came to fruition last
night when we're talking about it you
know every
you can use anybody's groups uh miami's
working really hard right now
um some of these things were set already
and and some
have just started but the tangible
things were important i thought
uh taking the breath was important just
needed a breather right i thought that
was important that's actually tangible
for the players
uh forming the coalition i thought was
fantastic because that's the future
you know it's not just now but uh
forming a coalition with coaches and
players
um and ownership and the league
uh and then hiring other people to come
in to help work that
i thought it's huge to get that done uh
voting is right now
so we're doing that right now we got to
get people to vote black men
uh we have black and brown men have to
vote have to vote
uh and so the registration um the
suppression right now
has never been higher uh our players
understood that and so that's important
um and so we just got to keep moving
forward and then the george floyd build
um we got to get that on the floor we
have to and
and so we're going to work to get that
done as well
thanks dan uh next question from andrew
greif
doc uh good to talk with you uh i was
just curious you know in terms of your
own team's discussions i'm sure you
weren't
part of every single one among the
players but i guess
how did those play out from from
wednesday night to thursday morning and
who'd you
like there's been some talk about kawhi
with someone who really was
spoke out at one point um kind of who
drove those discussions what did you
feel like
uh they all did we had a long discussion
that night in in the hallway
uh but i thought everyone uh i thought i
thought lou was fantastic kawhi was
fantastic
um you know marcus was was absolutely
wonderful
so there was a lot of guys who talked at
night you know i kept i was just sitting
there trying to get them to talk
um and and they did a lot of emotion
i think the thing i learned as a coach
um
you know where i would honestly admit
that i didn't see
how much effect the bubble has the
bubble has an effect
guys and and i'm the first to say i miss
that like and
and so i got to be better in seeing that
like uh how we can make this experience
better for our guys
that's nothing to do with politics or
anything else that's to do with real
life
and and so we have to we have to really
monitor that better
uh and i'm the first to say i knew it
was hard but i didn't i didn't see the
impact so we have to do better there
uh doc next question comes from chris
maddox there in orlando with you
did you leave the meeting wednesday
night thinking the clippers were going
home
no no i did not no
i think everyone else did um but
i just i knew how high the emotions were
and i just had a lot of faith in
that it would all come down i mean i
guess the report was the
electors and the clippers um i think it
was closed though
i don't think it was a layup either way
um
but i i did not doc we have a question
from
miriam go hey there doc um
uh i wasn't gonna ask you oh you know
the fact that you that all the guys got
together in a room and how powerful that
was
are are there plans to do that more
often to have sort of big wise
that's a great question i don't know
that you know it's funny we talked about
that uh i remember cp and i talked
first day we got here and i thought it
would be a good idea
um to do it this was when nothing was
going on
um and uh you know he told me it was
hard to get everybody
because all the practice schedules and
stuff so i think
it would wouldn't be a bad idea to just
get the
the room's feelings you know no needing
coaches there
um just them talking i think is very
important
great doc and we have one last question
um from
taylor rooks go ahead taylor okay doc so
we talk a lot about perspective
but in years to come when history tells
the story about these past couple days
what story do you want it to tell oh man
that's too deep um
you know i want them to tell the story
about what they're speaking about now
that the league is doing something
whenever that story is told
uh they're talking about what's
happening at that moment
that it started then the reason i say
that that means they're still doing it
um and this i'm just hoping
is now one one type one hit wonder thing
this has to
continue and i think that's why the
coalition is so important
uh because this is not about just today
something's gonna happen next week
next month um and we have to have a
group in place
to understand how to handle that and
understand how to help the players
process through it
um and and we have to have
a group that is working on legislation
uh
all the time not just um you know u.s
but with state to state legislation and
so
um i think that's the story that i want
though
thanks guys thank you